Trump and Kim jong-un got together and
they hit it off did you they really
seemed to hit it off yeah yeah this is
the latest true story president Trump
said Kim jong-un is absolutely invited
to the White House so he said yeah
unless of course Kim jong-un wins the
Super Bowl or the NBA championship
[Applause]
yesterday Kim jong-un and president
Trump had lunch and they were served
haagen-dazs ice cream yeah that was a
special occasion for the North Koreans
because they've never heard of
haagen-dazs or lunch
[Applause]
[Music]
they're starving strange very strange I
mean I said it but you applauded what's
going on recently when asked about the
Neetu movement Bill Clinton said the
norms have changed for what you can do
to somebody against their will yeah when
asked why he said that Clinton said I
like to say things that will haunt me
the rest of my life speaking of
presidents this is nice George HW Bush
turned 94 today he is now he is now the
oldest living president ever
yeah Bush toasted himself saying suck it
Thomas Jefferson that's terrible in New
York City yesterday in New York City
yesterday an uber driver kicked a
lesbian couple out of his car after they
kissed the real story here is that Mike
Pence drives for uber
[Applause]
you